The diagram that we get works as follows. Let's for instance look at the two red curves.
They show the effect the initial value has on the result.
It changes the initial value up and down by 5 * 10â´ tons and you get this curve and that curve.
You can immediately spot that this blue curve belongs to a factor that's more critical.
The blue one is the carrying capacity, and obviously,
the most critical is M for magenta, the maximum growth rate.
If we want to improve the reliability of our result, we definitely need to work on the uncertainty
of all maximum growth rate as opposed to what we just did.
This code doesn't look at the complete temporal evolution, it just looks at one single value,
the total amount of harvest for that particular set of parameters.
It compares what happens when that factor goes up to what happens when that factor goes down
and then determines the factor for which this difference is largest.
When you show here as we increase the value of that factor, the result may go down,
and as we decrease the value of that factor, the result may go up,
so that we end up with a negative sign of the difference here.
This is why we're using the absolute value and corresponding to what we guessed from the curves,
the most critical parameter is the maximum growth rate.